ya
ben de size Bence dediğimizi
özelliklerimizin kurbanı hayvanlardan
bahsedeceğim yazılışını sebebiyle bencil
doğuyoruz ve her şeyi kontrol
edebileceğinizi Egemen olabileceğimizi
düşünüyoruz bu bence kontrolü sağlamaya
çalışırken de en çok zararlı hayvanları
biliyoruz
kimlerin sesini zaman zaman Duysak da
bazen için duyamıyoruz belki de duymak
istemiyoruz kısaca geçmişten günümüze
insanlarla hayvanlar ilişkisine bakacak
olursa insanlık doğuşunu itibaren
hayvanlarda içeceğim
her ya zamanda arkadaşımız yoldaşımız
koruyucu muz oldular ama her zaman
doğaya çevreye hayvanlara zarar vermeye
evindeydik dediğim gibi Bence doğduk
Bence geçiyoruz Teknoloji ne zaman
ilerlemesiyle beraber bencilce
egemenliği sağlamaya çalışırken iyice
kontrolsüz eşlik ve hayvanlara doğaya
çevreye verdiğimiz zararları güreşteki
arttırdık artmaya devam ediyoruz Ben bu
konuyla seçtim kısaca bundan bahsetmek
istiyorum mi Evet mevzu İlk çıktığında
ne konuşabilirim de konuşabilirim diye
düşünürken ve Felsefe hocamız Hoca derse
bir etkinlikle geldi sınıf ikiye böldü
ellerimize kağıtlar verdi ve kağıtlarda
kısaca şu an anlatacağım hayvanlarla
ilgili şiddetler yazıyordu bizden
bunları En azından En kötüsü
sıralamanızı istedi bizde bunu takımcı
Oldukça hızlı bir şekilde bitirdik ve
sınıf ortamına tartışmaya başladık bu
tartışmayı yaparken Aslında çoğu şey
kafanda masum ulaştırdığı mı Bazı
hakkında hiçbir fikre sahip olmadığını
gördüm ve dedim ki ben bu konuyu
araştırıp ses konuşmanın konusu
yapabilirim bugün karşınızdayım bu
etkinliği sizlerle beraber de yapmak
istiyorum kalp.com a girip hemen
girebilirsiniz çok güzel olur kalk
açabiliriz
bu
kodumuz 405 83 59
Evet
hepinize bekliyorum
1405 83 59
bu Turkish olduk
abone ol
bu birazcık daha bekleyip beş saniye
sonra başlatabiliriz tamam
başlayabiliriz zaten tek soruluk bir
kahoot
abone ol
ve En kötüsünü seçmenizi istiyorum
burada dört tane şık var Ben sekiz
maddeden başlatmaya bahsedeceğim
mi Evet
11 cevap
bu 29
ben sana beş saniye
bu çoğunuz ağacında seçmişsiniz dört
kişi İpek kumaşlar 8 kişi kıyılara
Festivali 11 kişi kuş tüyü yastıkları
seçmiş Ama genel olarak Avcılar çok
yüklendiğini görüyoruz
Biz şimdi sunuma geçebiliriz
o kendi listemi üzerinden gitmek
istiyorum Bana göre sırası nasılmış ona
bakalım bana göre elmasum
o geçebilir miyiz
ama
bana göre elması mı at yarışları ve
faytonlar atlar koşmak için dolmuşlar
bunu hepimiz hemfikiriz anasır biraz
eğleneceğiz ya da Para kazanacağız diye
yedikleri kırbaşlar kabul edilir halimi
geliyor ya da Fatih onlarda insanları
gün boyu amaçsızca oradan oraya
götürüyorlar ve yol ve yorulduk ları
için yavaşladığında ise dayak yiyorlar
Ama siz geziniz evde tatilinde farkında
bilmeseniz hayatımızdan hiçbir şey
kaybetmezsiniz ama faydalanabilmeniz
biraz için kırbacı değişebilir
bir diğer maddemiz hayvanat bahçeleri ve
simitler Bu da bir çoğunuz için masum
gelebilir ama asla öyle bir Tabii ki çok
iyi bakın oradan hayvanat bahçeleri var
ama hayvanların elde edilme yöntemi her
zaman aynı hayvanlar daha yavruyken
doğal yaşam alanlarının alınır kafese
koyuyorlar ve bir oyuncak bebek mis gibi
sergileniyor var Sizler de ise durum
daha kötü oradan Reis yükleniyorlar
yapıları gereği yapamayacakları
yapmayacakları hareketleri öğreniyorlar
ve yapamadıklarımda ise günlerce aç
bakıyorlar 10 şovları izlemeye gidiyoruz
ve bu insanlara para kazandırıyoruz
ya bildiğiniz üzere birçok hayvan türü
tehlike altında bunun en büyük sebebi
küresel ısınma bir yerde avcılık küresel
ısınmayı Biz gerçekleştiriyoruz ama ben
bugün hazırlıktan bahsedeceğim avcılık
spor olarak geçiyor ve spor adasına
hayvanlar öldürülüyor hayvan öldürmeye
geçtim bilinçsiz yapılan avcılıkta
hayvan neslini tehlikeye giriyor Bunun
dışında delisi ve kürk için alınan
hayvanlar da var tilkiler ve timsahlar
gibi yılda sadece kürkü için alınan
tilki sayısı 3000000 Bu da aklınızda şu
şekilde canlanabilir
856 tane Boğaz Köprüsü uzunluğuna
tekabül ediyor Bunun dışında yine kedi
ve köpek sayısı 3000000 vizon sayısı
45000000 topladığı sayısı 300 binden
fazla bu şöyle gördüğünüz çantanın
yapımı için dört tane timsahın kat
edilmesi gerekiyor
Bu bir diğer maddemiz kuştüyü yastıklar
ya da yorganlar kavgada vardı
birçoğunuzun aslında bu yazdıklarım
Aslında açtığını düşünüyorum Çünkü ben
de öyleydim öyle hayvanlardan alındığını
düşünüyorum maalesef böyle değilmiş
hayvanlar canlı olarak kafeslere koyulup
şeyler o şekilde alıyormuş bunun canlı
yapılmasını iki sebebi var Birincisi
tüyleri kanaması engellemek İkincisi ise
hayvanlar tekrar tülince için masraftan
kaçınmak genelleme olarak bakacak
olursak
yumurtalar için beslenen hayvanlar yılda
ömürleri boyunca 10-15 kere et için
beslenenler 5-6 kere yolunuyor ve eğer
olgun tüyler yolunuzda değerlerine
tahrişe ve yansımalara sebep oluyor
Bununla ilgili kısa videolar bakalım
tüyler nasıl alınıyormuş
bu the protein ve hala Emirgan volt araç
Eskişehir Merhaba hocam
bu ay
hemen hemen aynı ifade var ama bu konu
hakkında ne yazık ki hiçbir şey
yapmıyoruz Biz yataklarımız da daha
rahat uyuyacağız ya bu kuşlar ömürleri
boyunca 10-15 kere bu acı çekiyorlar
seslenen anlamışsınızdır zaten ne kadar
acı verici olduğunu bir diğer maddemiz
ipek böcekleri böcekleri örümcekleri
görüşlerinden dolayı pek çoğunu
sevmiyoruz göz ardı ediyoruz düşünüyoruz
ama İpek bu hikayesi oldukça acıklı
kullandığımız İpek kumaşlar bu
böceklerin kozaların elde ediliyor fakat
şöyle bir sorun var ipek böcekleri
kozadan çıkarken Koza yırtıkları için
kullanılamaz hale Getiriyorlar Sırf bu
yüzden de böcekler kazaları ördükten
sonra kaynak suları suları atılıp ha
yazıyor
Bu bir diğer maddemiz Fildişi filler
kendi halinde yaşayan zararsız devasa
boyutta hayvanlardır bu durum bazı
acılar rahatsız ediyor olacak ki dişleri
için anlamıyorlar yapılan araştırmalara
göre bozan bitti dişi fillerin avcılık
ve kaçakçılık yüzünden dilsiz doğdu
ortaya çıkmış Daha öncesinde dişlerin
kısalığına dair araştırmalar yapılmıştı
avlanan hayvan oracıkta ölüme terk
ediliyor ve bu sadece avlanan gibi değil
yavru etkiliyor annesiyle beraber
dolaşan yavru fil annesini ölümünden
sonra depresyona giriyor ve eğer birkaç
saat içerisinde gerekli müdahale
yapılmazsa kederinden ölüyor şurada
gördüğünüz fotoğraf okul kurucumuz
Abdulkadir bey tarafından Kenya'da
çekildim kenya'daki fetishist onu
bitirmek için hepsi yapılmış bile döküp
dönüştürmüş çok kısa gözüküyorsun
çıkabileceğiniz Tepecik Aslında ve
bulunan onlarca var
bu Eymen şekilde fiillerle ilgili
Holiday in White diye bir film var
romantik komedi filmi Eğer seviyorsanız
en güzel yerde ilişkiler fiillerle
ilgili romantik-komedi seviyorsanız
izleyebilirsiniz
Bu bir daha maddemiz kınada Festivali bu
Festival ile duymuşsunuzdur birçok kez
gündeme geldi Çünkü
herkese marka düzenleniyor binlerce
Alina öldürülüyor Bunun sebebi ise balık
çatalı anlat geçen sene 1428 Yunus ve
balina katledildi beniz kıyısı
kıpkırmızı oldu kana bulandı ne kadar
linç edilse de kutlanmaya devam ediyor
Büyük ihtimalle bu sene tutunacak
bakalım bu yunusların nasıl alıyorlar
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu videonun devamı oldukça vahşet
içeriyor ve yani oldukça korkunç bir
görüntü maalesef Bunun hakkında yine
hiçbir şey yapmıyoruz ve bu yıl yine
kutlanmaya devam edecek museb Alina
nesillerin de oldukça tehlikeye atıyor
hiç bir derman temiz hayvan deneyleri Ve
bu son maddemiz Bana kalırsa en
acımasızı bu çoğunuz için böyle olduğunu
düşünüyorum Bu hayvanlar bulmak için
yetiştiriliyor ömürleri boyunca
kafeslerde üzerine deneyler yapılıyor bu
deneylerin bu da neler asla bitmiyor
yani ne kadar kötü durumda olsalar da
deneyler devam ediyor ta ki örümcek
kadar yani kollarını bacaklarını gözünü
kaybetmiş hiç önemli değil ben neler
devam ediyor ve bu hayvanların çoğu
gökyüzünü görmemiş hayvandır Bu da
nelerin yapılmaması İsa genel olarak
saçlarımız daha parlak gözüksün Trabzon
sanız daha güzel koksun diye geçen sene
Survivor etiketiyle gündeme gelmişti
aynı hızlı gündemden çıktı çoğu insan
için tabii bazı markalar hayvanların
elini dur durdu çoğu insan artık
hayvanların yapan markalar kullanmıyor
ama maalesef devam ediyor serafin
videosundan bir kesit aldığım bakalım
tekrar bize ne diyor
Gördüğünüz üzere bir tavşanım bu
sağ gözün çorba bu kulağın duymuyor
sadece çınlıyor duymak ister misiniz
Evet
bu
ve sırtında biraz kimyasal döküldü biraz
taşınıyor
çok önemli değil Nefes alırken etrafta
dolaşırken çok acıtmıyor aşkım ya
işte
sorun yok değil mi
dediği gibi bunu insanlar için
yapıyorlarsa bir sorun yok öyle değil mi
benim ismimi eklemediğim daha onlarca
hayvanlar karette karettalar Scottish
cinsi kediler Afrika'daki Aslanlar gibi
bunlar Sadece başlıcaları bu
anlattıklarım yanı sıra şimdi
anlatacaklarım tamamen psikopattan
ibaret ilahi görmüşsünüzdür sosyal
medyada haberlerde hayvanın tekmelerim
korku Tanrı geçtim boks torbası niyetine
kullananlar Çuvala koyup oraya
savuranlar veya ki bu olay geçen sene
yaşandı kışın aç kalmasınlar diye
koyulan mama kapları Evet tamam bu
insanlar da suçlu bu insanlar da Katil
ve bu insanlar da ceza almalı ama biz
toplum olarak bu insanlara karşı gözüne
bakmadığımız için bu şiddet bu işkence
hala devam ediyor dilimizde hayvan olma
hayvan gibi davranma gittiği biterim var
biliyorsunuzdur biz bazen hayvanlardan
daha hayvan oluyoruz Peki biz bunu nasıl
durdurabiliriz rahatımız dan ve zevk
lerimizden biraz taviz vererek yani
timsah test çantanızı olmasa tilki kürkü
montsuz olmasa hayvanat bahçesi sirke
gitmezseniz hayatınızdan hiçbir şey
kaybetmezsiniz hiçbir şey ama bir
insanın bunları yapmaması onlarca ilk
insanı cool onlarca hayvanı kurtarabilir
Sözümü bir hikaye gitmek istiyorum
avcunuzdaki kelebek hikayesi belki
bilenleriniz vardır
en uzun zaman önce iki tane kardeş
varmış oldukça Zeki Kardeşler miş
okuldaki eğitimlerinden yetersiz
buluşlar ve bu yüzden bir bilgi adamla
tanışmışlar sorularını bilgi adama
sormuşlar bilgi adam bütün soruları
ustalıkla cevap vermiş Bu da birazcık
kardeşleri sıkmış birazcık sinir
olmuşlar ve demişler ki biz bu adama
bilemeyeceği bir soru soralım
düşünmüşler taşınmışlar kardeşine
kardeşlerden birinin aklına bir fikir
gelmiş avuçların arasına bir kelebek
olacaklar ve soracaklar kelebek canlı
ölümü Adam canlı derse yeni
başlayacaklar kelebek ölecek adam öldü
derse elleri açacaklar kendime kucak
adamın yanına gitmişler soruyu sormuşlar
kelebek bölümü canımı adam demiş ki
sizin elinizde yardım sizin elinizden
aynı şekilde burada bahsettiğim
hayvanların yaşaması ölmesi ya da
işkence görmesi sizlerinde maalesef buna
biz karar veriyoruz şimdi s ve bu
kelebeğin yaşamasına izin vereceksiniz
yoksa üzerine bastırıp ölmesine sebep
olacaksınız teşekkür ederim